apparently Buddha judge is going he's
rushing there now I'm telling you the
EPA is the federal government is
reacting to Trump saying he was going to
be there Trump said this Friday night
and they're like oh goodness we have to
beat him there because if he goes
especially to a county he won twice in a
state he won twice and then is like I am
here for you and the Biden Ministry is
not in fact not even the bite
Administration Pete Kamala Harris anyone
who might seek to replace Biden
it's it's an unbeatable moment for Trump
and Trump mean a lot to the people who
voted him and who voted for him in the
first place Trump should show up with a
checkbook and just start writing
thousand dollar checks to yeah and make
a viral video of it then just like that
was my move oh no you can be like shout
out to Betty Benny Johnson did it first
but it was a tremendous idea so we're
going to do it